we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
you can call the voicemail number
anytime you want and
here's a really good question about all
of these so-called
voter integrity measures that
republicans have been and want to
continue passing take a listen to this
hey david these voter suppression
tactics
it's kind of hard to find the um
statistical analysis on their effect
could you could you share what percent
what percentage do they estimate
uh that these these tactics prevent
illegal voting or versions of that and
what percentage of voters who
want to vote yeah are unable to vote
because they've been purged from a voter
roll
uh or other suppression tactic where
they
they said they were unable to vote i'm
just assuming that they estimate that
based on polls or something else
yeah so this this is a good question
which is all this stuff republicans do
legally speaking um in order to
prevent illegal voting how much illegal
voting does it actually prevent versus
how many
legal voters end up being
disenfranchised which is really the
design of it
there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that in-person voter fraud
is a materially significant issue now
it's important to say materially
significant because republicans will
hear that
and they'll write in and they'll say
what about jim bob who uh
voted twice or what about bobby sue
who figured out how to vote under her
cousin's name or whatever
the the question is you know in a
country of 331 million people there are
examples of everything
is there any evidence that all of these
in-person types of voter fraud are
materially
significant to election results and the
answer is no
on the other hand we know of tons of
people who
were purged from voter rolls for
so-called inactivity
uh who were denied the ability to vote
because of other
uh clerical um issues that were caused
by
these guidelines and restrictions put in
place by republicans there are people
who opted just not to even go and vote
because republicans disproportionately
shut down voting
booths and curtail voting hours in
disproportionately democratic areas so
the the brennan center for justice has a
lot of great data on this
and the most important takeaway is the
voter
suppression tactics from republicans
because that's what they are which they
claim to be uh in the spirit of
preventing illegal votes
they do way more to interfere with
people legally voting
than they do to curb what is almost
insignific
almost non-existent and statistically
insignificant
in-person voter fraud the real way
that you affect elections is by
suppressing the vote at the big picture
level
you don't flip an election by going with
your friends to multiple
polling places and claiming to be
different people
you don't go and round up the people who
are juniors and say even though your
dad's senior is dead
go and vote for yourself and for your
dad no that's not how you steal an
election
just doesn't happen and uh the question
is is well asked and really gets to the
heart of that
we have a great bonus show for you today
teenagers
are helping each other get covered shots
when their parents are anti-vaxx
fascinating that this is what's going on
the
defiant uh action of teenagers
is to get themselves vaccinated even
when their parents don't want them to
unbelievable
but trials to suck carbon dioxide from
the air are going to start across the
united kingdom
and the texas senate has approved a bill
limiting
how race and racism can be taught in
public school classrooms
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show i would love it
if you joined us on the bonus show pat
will be joining me why don't you join me
as well
you can get instant access by signing up
at joinpakman.com